pris pour des imbéciles soir je sais pas
exactement ce qui s'est passé mais ce
qui est vrai c'est qu'il fait beaucoup
et parfois avec succès de confiance à
son charme et donc il fait du charme
bon apparemment hier soir il n'a pas
fait exactement mais dans son discours
avec les maires c'est ça il n'est pas
fini c'est un peu tôt pour en parler
mais il leur fait dans la forme beaucoup
de charme sur le fond moelleux la
première partie que j'ai entendu il
recule sur rien il fait un petit mea
culpa sur cet été en disant on vous
impliquez 300 millions là peut-être
qu'on n'a pas été fait assez de
concertation mais après sur le fond de
deux des mesures d'économies qui
l'annoncent pour les années qui viennent
u17 mans confiance elles sont
nécessaires de notation vous êtes
comptable des deniers publics comme nous
tous
et puis l'europe nous attend et puis 8
face on reverra la fiscalité locale plus
tard mais hercules pas sûr sur super
pares